well the parents of three special needs
students are now suing the clark county
school district after they say their
children were abused in the classroom
yeah it's a story you're seeing
here first on eight news now the
i-team's vanessa murphy is live with
exclusive interviews and the journey the
families say they're on
to get justice
parents say school leaders failed to
tell them their children
were abused and their lawyers say this
lawsuit
isn't just about what may have happened
at one school
they point to a system which they say
fails
to protect children but i'm hurt
and i'm devastated that my son
had to go through this i just feel so
guilty about that that
i couldn't see it because it's something
i'd never imagined
i just i couldn't believe it three
parents of students with special needs
say they've tried to piece together what
happened in a theory at elementary third
grade classroom
unique barnett received a call from
child protective services
it advised me of the situation where my
son and a few of his classmates were
involved with the
teacher and some hands-on abuse
and they were being whipped with the
stick he refers to as paulo paulo
and so he was whipping them on their
hands on their bottoms
records show a timeline on september 11
2019
three employees report concerns to the
principal on the 12th employee
management relations tells the principal
to investigate
by friday the 13th the assistant
principal says
students say they've been hit principal
sonja holdsworth called ccsd
police dispatch the i-team obtained the
recording of the call
she was talking to them and she said to
them what is this called and they said
paula paulo and she said oh what does it
mean and they knew it meant to spank
they're all pretty much having the same
story though yeah they are
they are that's what this is where we're
really scared so we can't tell anybody
about this
we have to keep it quiet
we can't even tell special ed like we're
not even gonna tell them
that friday afternoon special needs
teacher shane batuyan
is put on leave with pay pending an
investigation communications tells the
principal to let the parents know that
petuyon's on leave
on monday school police are a no-show
but cps shows up to the school
officers arrive at the school tuesday
afternoon
six days after concerns were first
reported police begin an investigation
barnett says she first learned about the
investigation from
cps not from school leaders or police
it made me panic i'm at home i just sent
my kid to the war zone he's
being abused police say battulion denied
hitting the children but he said he told
them the stick was a magic wand to give
them powers and it was a secret
detectives concluded that six students
were hit tapped or poked
and recommended charges be filed against
him for six counts of battery
two other parents maria garcia and larry
bracamontes say they were not
told their children were identified as
victims by police
until barnett's lawyers contacted them a
year later
what i want is the ccnc take
responsibility
to be held accountable because
they knew garcia's daughter is
considered non-verbal
petuyen's aide told police he told her
to take students to another classroom
every day garcia is concerned she
doesn't know about what may have
happened if her daughter was alone with
him
that we take our children to school
thinking they're going to be
safe and they're not the three families
have filed a federal lawsuit against
ccsd the principal and assistant
principal the aide and batuyan
a relative of petullians tells the
i-team he believes he's in the
philippines
we discovered he still has a nevada
teaching license
a spokeswoman for the department of
education tells the i-team the
department
recently learned about allegations and
will investigate
by law ccsd is required to report
aversive intervention against
children with disabilities including
corporal punishment
attorneys for the parents provided these
documents revealing
zero reported during that school year
when reached by phone wednesday
principal holdsworth told the i-team all
protocols were followed
but attorneys for the families allege
concealment
it shows a culture of disregard
and abuse of these children which just
needs to stop the i-team has also
learned the district attorney's office
did
not pursue charges against battulian
citing insufficient
evidence another let down for these
parents
they failed his kids
hi woman
lawyers allege that the aide also abused
students we are not naming her in this
report this evening because
as far as we know police did not
recommend
charges against her i have asked ccsd
if she is still an employee i'm still
waiting for an answer
ccsd did send me a statement stating
they do
not comment on pending litigation
vanessa regarding the allegations were
there any cameras present
as far as we know no cameras typically
they are not
in classrooms at ccsd this is something
especially special needs advocates have
fought for
for years usually ccsd is
against that and a quick follow-up do
you know this individual
batuyon taught anywhere else any other
school
according to records he taught at
another middle school that's why lawyers
believe
there may be more possible victims we're
going to put
more information about their firm and
that school
at eightnewsnow.com